[Music]
what did you do this weekend Diana me
huh nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman he said the age of heroes
who never come again
it has to
[Music]
we don't have anymore time
[Music]
something is calling
no vegetation
no language
[Music]
your kryptonian
[Music]
which made this yeah
buckle
well this is the days where mom's
biggest concerns were exploding windup
penguins this is crazy
I was I think wrong and I
each of us in some way is held back
John engage alone until this together
really cool you guys seem ready to do
battle and stuff
relax Alfred don't take it from here do
I know you
Superman was a beacon to the world
you don't save people
to see the best parts of themselves
I recognize as well
we don't have to recognize
which is absurd
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think that oh wow they just
they really just vanish huh oh that's
rude
he said you've come now that's hope
you're not too late
yeah
we have to be ready
you the others
just attack coming from far away
not coming loose it's already here the
others where are they Arthur curry the
Aquaman
so never again and couldn't
biomechatronics body parts he's a cyborg
you should probably move very Alan
whoever you're looking for it's not me
is it Batman
they said the Age of Heroes would never
come again pass to
[Applause]
what are your superpowers again I'm rich
watch our
shall we
it's good to see you playing well with
others again just like a bat I dig it
may be temporary
there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea it comes in the
winter when people are hungry brings
fish comes on the king tide that was
last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away I'm looking for warriors
is stranger others like him
[Music]
I'm building an alliance to defend us
it's a very important that I see this
man Barry Allen first way you said that
like it explains why there's a total
stranger sitting in the dark in my
second favorite chair
he said he'll fight with us more or less
[Music]
probably more or less he said no they
said no look man I don't know who you
are but whoever you're looking for
[Music]
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team with special abilities
you see I believe enemies are coming and
stop right there
I'm in you are just like that
yeah I need friends right gotta keep
this
[Applause]
I heard about you didn't think you were
real
I'm realise useful
[Music]
Arthur curry here you can talk to fish
[Music]
stranger who comes to this village from
the sea he comes in the winter when
people are hungry brings fish he comes
on the king tide that was last night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just want to say quick thanks to my
cast and crew it's been a great sheet
and Thank You UK amazing
[Applause]
[Music]